Mass disappearances, promiscuous priests?!
Critics can’t stop gobbling gabbagool — so
are they breaking bad or are these
really the best television drama seasons?
Although "The Americans" finished strong, the
show's creative peak came during its 4th season,
as it was around this point in the
show that many of the central plot
points came to fruition. Specifically,
Philip's relationship with Martha,
a government employee he's been quietly
siphoning information out of for years,
finally comes undone when he is forced to frame
Gene, one of Martha's coworkers, for her spying.
Martha's exfiltration causes a rift between Philip
and Elizabeth, and ultimately leads both of them
to question their loyalty to a country they
haven't set foot in for years. At the same time,
their daughter Paige is now fully aware that
her parents are Russian spies. By the end of
the season, she's considering entering the
spy game herself. The season's final moments
emphasize the price that Philip and Elizabeth
have had to pay as a result of their profession.
"The Americans" was always a grim show, but Season
4 spends a huge portion of its run time examining
what being a spy does to a person's soul. Philip
and Elizabeth are hollow shells of people,
and by the end of the season, they realize
that's not the fate they want for their daughter.
"Don't do this, Paige."
"Dad!"
"You have no idea. No idea."
The docu-drama series "The Staircase"
began in 2004 as an early contribution
to the now-wildly popular true crime genre.
It follows the trial of Michael Peterson,
who was convicted of murdering his wife, Kathleen.
After a successful first season, the
showrunners published more installments
based on updates in the case in 2013
and 2018. The miniseries, directed by
Jean-Xavier de Lestrade chronicles not only the
twists and turns of the original case, but also
how corruptible the justice system is and the
horrible toll that prison can take on a person.
While precious few miniseries provide viewers the
satisfaction of definitive proof regarding the
truth behind a crime, "The Staircase" relishes
in the ambiguous set of facts that surround the
case. Whether or not Michael Peterson was
guilty of the crime he was convicted for,
his family and the audience must live
with the uncertainty about whether he
deserved the punishment he ultimately
received for the crime he was convicted.
It's always disappointing to
see shows as great as "Enlightened" get canceled,
especially after the show repeatedly achieved new
heights throughout its 2nd and final season.
The series tells the story of Amy Jellicoe,
a career-oriented woman who has a breakdown
and ends up at Open Air, a rehabilitation
program in Hawaii. When she returns from the
program a sunnier, peppier version of herself,
she discovers that reacclimating to her old life
might not be as straightforward as she expected.
In Season 2, "Enlightened" transforms
Amy into an impassioned crusader whose
only goal is to take down the company
she once worked for. She spends the
season working with a journalist
known for uncovering corruption,
but ultimately discovers that the systems she's
trying to destroy are much harder to take down
than she thought. Like so many people in modern
America, Amy wants to be an advocate for change,
but she's caught between her fierce idealism and
the intractable nature of modern capitalism. Huge,
multinational companies just don't play
by the same rules as the rest of us.
It was easy to be
dismissive of Noah Hawley's decision to adapt
"Fargo," the 1996 Coen Brothers masterpiece,
into a TV series of the same name. Even after the
1st season, it wasn't entirely clear how Hawley
was going to transform this story into something
that could last for years. After Season 2, though,
"Fargo" proved that fans of the original film
could stop worrying so much about the adaptation.
The show's 2nd season dives back into the late
1970s, a time when many Americans felt like
their country was in decline, to tell a story
of warring crime families and intergenerational
conflict. The narrative is beautifully
paced through the season's 10 episodes,
and all of the actors know how to make a meal out
of the peculiar dialect that the show relies on.
"Okay, then."
By telling a story about people who lash
out and hurt one another for no reason,
"Fargo" Season 2 explores the limits
of what we can know about human nature.
While both a serious drama and a compelling
comedy, "Fleabag" Season 2 is also a love story.
The 1st season followed Phoebe Waller-Bridge's
titular character as she excavated the traumas
of her past and her own role in creating them.
In Season 2, Fleabag attempts to move forward,
and ultimately finds herself attracted to
a Catholic priest. The two consummate their
relationship before the priest decides that
his dedication must remain with his faith.
"Fleabag" is funnier and
sharper in its 2nd season,
but it's every bit as devastating as it was in
its initial run. As these episodes make clear,
the fourth-wall-breaking that has been
a core part of the show's style is also
a coping mechanism for the show's main
character. Fleabag talks to the camera
and the audience to distance herself from
the world immediately in front of her.
"Cheers, may these be the worst of our days!"
"Don't know who this guy is."
In the season's final moments, though, she leaves
the camera behind, ready to lead a life in which
she's fully engaged with the people around her.
She may have lost out on the handsome priest,
but her ill-starred love for him
gave her maturity and humility.
Laura Palmer is dead. That's the simple
premise of "Twin Peaks," one that horrifies
creators David Lynch and Mark Frost as much
as it enthralls them. Across its 1st season,
"Twin Peaks" aired 8 nearly perfect
episodes that were focused on finding
Laura's killer and discovering the
town of Twin Peaks' seedy underbelly.
Across those eight hours, "Twin Peaks" combined
elements of a murder investigation with small-town
drama, science fiction, and even a few helpful
handfuls of soap opera storytelling. As with
much of Lynch's work, the tone is nightmarishly
surreal and incredibly stylish, complicating what
at first glance might seem like a standard police
procedural. Twin Peaks feels like a normal town,
but it's hiding a darkness as deep
and terrifying as the pits of hell.
Although the show stumbled in its later seasons,
the 1st season alone made "Twin Peaks" one of the
most important and impactful TV series of
all time. Decades after its 1990 air date,
it still feels like audiences aren't fully
ready for what the show has to offer.
"Homeland" rode the wave of rave reviews
for its 1st season into its 2nd. Although
the critical reception to the show
eventually became less rapturous,
Season 2 proved to be a high watermark. The
show follows Carrie, a CIA agent with bipolar
disorder who becomes convinced that a
returning war veteran named Brody has
been turned by al-Qaeda. After Brody fails
to detonate a bomb meant to assasinate the
vice president at the end of Season 1, Season
two deals with the fallout from his inaction.
Carrie and Brody eventually strike up
a relationship, which only complicates
Carrie's place inside the CIA. The espionage on
"Homeland" is a huge part of the show's appeal,
but the relationships between its
characters are what make the show
feel truly lived-in. "Homeland" was a
phenomenon upon its initial release,
and the reviews for Season 2 proved that
it was a series with some staying power.
Season 2 of "The Sopranos" was able to
build off of the excitement that many critics had
after the show's incredible first season. Although
some have come to see the 2nd season as a bit of
a letdown, it's also received plenty of praise.
In the 2nd season, Tony discovers that one
of his closest friends is an FBI informant,
and he continues to see Dr. Melfi in spite
of her increasing disgust over what he
does for a living. Meanwhile, Tony's sister
returns to his life, and she and Tony must
confront their complicated relationship
with each other and with their mother.
The 2nd season of "The Sopranos" is every bit as
strong as the 1st, even if it lacks some of the
shock factor that made those initial episodes
so celebrated. With its second installment,
"The Sopranos" solidified its status as superb
television and proved it was in for the long haul.
By the time "The Sopranos" was in its
3rd season, it had cemented itself as
one of the best TV shows on air, and
possibly of all time. In Season 3,
the show dives even deeper into Tony's psyche
and the reason for his continued panic attacks,
and we get deeper insights into Tony's
relationships with his children. This
season also gave fans one of the best—and
hardest to watch—episodes of the entire series,
in which Dr. Melfi is understandably tempted to
make use of her client's extrajudicial power.
The genius of "The Sopranos" was the way the show
managed to put equal emphasis on every aspect of
its character's lives. The mob storylines
were as compelling as ever, and they were
only made more interesting by the insight the
show provided into Tony's life outside of work.
Throughout the show, there's little separation
between Tony's family and his criminal activity,
and as his children grow up and attempt to chart
their own courses, that only becomes more evident.
"Is mom there?"
"Yeah, she's here. How's school?"
"Fine, is mom there?"
Given the fact that it's widely regarded
as one of the great TV dramas of all time,
it should come as little surprise that
several seasons of "The Sopranos" made
it onto this list. While it's common for
popular shows to taper out near the end,
"The Sopranos" stayed strong
right up to its finale.
The controversy over the finale
tends to overshadow the fact that
Season 6 was consistently great long
before that abrupt cut to black. The
6th season was split into two parts,
with 12 episodes airing in one block,
followed by an additional 9-episode
run to conclude the entire series.
Many of the members of Tony's criminal
organization seem to be on a path towards
redemption, but they're all ultimately
pulled back into the violent life of
crime they've been leading all along. They
may believe that they're capable of change,
but as the final season shows, becoming a
new person is much harder than it seems.
"We're soldiers, ya know?.
Soldiers don't go to hell."
By the time Season 3 rolled around,
"The Leftovers" was the definition of a critical
darling. After a divisive first season and a
critically adored second, expectations were high
for the third installment. Luckily for showrunners
and fans alike, the series' third season
delivered. Set seven years after the departure
that launched the series, Season 3 focuses on the
show's core characters as they reckon with whether
or not they've actually evolved in the years since
two percent of the world's population vanished.
The show is just as strange as ever in Season
3, which shifts much of the action to Australia
as some characters begin to suspect that
the end of the world is imminent. In just
eight short episodes, the show manages to
tie off many of its central relationships,
and also provides glimmers of hope for characters
who have spent much of the series totally lost.
"The world is ending."
In a brutal, perfect finale, we see the character
of Nora living alone in the distant future after
attempting to reunite with the family she lost
on Departure Day. The episode is beautiful,
haunting, and lovely, and it's a great showcase
for leading actors Justin Theroux and Carrie Coon,
who give two exceptional performances
as the show's broken, desperate leads.
After an incredible first season, "The Wire"
returned for a second season that dazzled critics.
With a focus on the effects broken and corrupt
systems have on the lives of its characters,
Season 2 depicted the ways in which the
dock workers were ultimately connected
to the drug trade and to an international crime
syndicate that flourished as a result. It also
achieved the rare distinction of making a
compelling drama out of the seemingly dry
subject matter of union politics like
seniority rights and decertification.
The 2nd season of "The Wire" also takes
a hard look at the decline of the working
class, showing how the changing world has
destabilized labor. As the world moves forward,
many essential workers get left behind.
"The Wire" was about one city's problems,
but they often felt so universal that
anyone could empathize with them.
Considered by critics to be the pinnacle of the
show's quality, Season three of "The Wire" has
a lot to offer. The season's central premise is
the creation of safe zones throughout the city
of Baltimore where drug activity is legal,
a situation hilariously dubbed "Hamsterdam."
It's a dangerous, high-stakes approach to
crime management that seems irresponsible,
but ultimately leads to lower levels of violence
in the district where the rules are put in place.
Ultimately, though, those safe zones are exposed,
and politicians use their existence to make
grandstanding speeches. Meanwhile, the drug war
continues unabated across the rest of the city,
and violence escalates to the point where Stringer
Bell is killed by Omar Little and Brother Mouzone.
The season is a masterpiece of carefully plotted
story, one that imagines a brighter future for
Baltimore that always seems to be just out
of reach. While "The Wire" never shied away
from the systemic nature of the problems it
depicted, Season 3 also showed how decisions
made by the people in those systems can
both reinforce and untangle those problems.
"You going back to your homes tonight,
we gonna be in our patrol cars,
and them boys still gonna be
out there on them corners."
The fourth season of "The Wire"
may be the most heartbreaking
of all. Each season of the show focused
on a different institution within urban
Baltimore. Season 4 turned the camera
on Baltimore's youth and the underfunded
school system that tries desperately
to keep them from turning to crime.
It's tough to watch how the system slowly corrupts
innocent children, but it gives audiences a full
picture of exactly how broken the world of "The
Wire" is while shedding light on how closely
the show mirrors reality. The seasons' other
major storyline, which involves the primary
race for Baltimore mayor, establishes how the
political machine stifles any attempt at reform.
Thomas Carcetti ascends to the office of
mayor intending to change the systems that
have trapped so many people in difficult
circumstances, but finds himself unable to
deliver. The frank look at municipal dysfunction
gets leavened by moments of gallows humor.
When "Breaking Bad" starts,
Walter White is an average guy. Maybe he's got
some anger issues, and maybe he feels stifled
by his job as a high school chemistry teacher,
but he's a dedicated family man. That changes
when he gets a cancer diagnosis, setting off a
chain of events that leads him to start making
and selling meth. By Season 4, Walt is still
alive, but he's become an irredeemable monster.
Season 4 is so well-regarded in part
because it's the season where Walt
fully embraces this transformation as
he attempts to take down Gus Fring,
the show's main villain. Walt wins his battle
with Gus, but it comes at the soul-corrupting
cost of poisoning a child and planting bombs
on an old man's wheelchair. These measures make
it clear that, by the end of Season 4, Walt
is willing to do anything to achieve power.
Aside from featuring a myriad of iconic
scenes, Season 4 plumbed the depths of each
of its characters, producing both tense drama
and a particularly dark shade of black comedy.
*Walt laughing*
"Breaking Bad" went out on top. In its 5th and
final season, Walt is finally making all the
calls. He's the head of his own meth empire,
and he's working with Mike and Jesse to become
one of the major forces in the southwest drug
trade. Much like "The Sopranos," the first half
of this split season depicts a near-meteoric rise
for Walt in the aftermath of Gus Fring's death.
Ultimately, though, that rise can't last. Walt's
brother-in-law, Hank, discovers that Walt is the
elusive meth dealer he's been tracking for
years. Hank's unraveling of Walt's secret
ultimately leads to Walt's downfall, as his
family loses everything and he's forced to
go on the run. Jesse winds up imprisoned by a
group of neo-Nazis, where he's forced to cook
meth or be cruelly tortured. In the end, Walt
finds some measure of redemption and humanity
by sacrificing himself to save Jesse. He also
finally admits to his wife, Skyler, that all
the horrible things he's done was for himself and
not a selfless mission to provide for his family.
Season 5 is a bleak masterpiece,
serving as a reminder that all the
terrible things audiences have
watched Walt do over the course
of the show will eventually come back
to haunt him and those he cares about.
"Rectify" is a story
about broken people working to make themselves
whole. The show follows a man who spent nearly
20 years on death row for a crime he didn’t
commit. DNA evidence ultimately exonerates him,
and he's released from prison.
When he returns to his hometown,
he finds it a strange place totally
unlike the one he left, and he's forced
to reckon with all of the relationships
he left behind when he was incarcerated.
Through every season, and especially in its
4th and final outing, "Rectify" was a quiet,
deeply moving character drama.
It never overplayed its hand,
and it allowed its characters to grow and change
as the episodes progressed. "Rectify" may not be
remembered as one of the best TV shows of
all time, but that's because it has none
of the flair or excitement that defined many
of the series on this list. Instead, it was
happy to be subtly contemplative and beautiful
in ways that most TV shows rarely try to be.
"Genndy Tartakovsky's Primal"
is clearly a long-simmering,
delicately-executed passion project for
its creator, an animation titan who looms
so large over his world that his name is in the
title. The series is one of the most ambitious,
visually deep, and gorgeous TV cartoons
in decades. An epic fantasy quest,
"Primal" feels more reminiscent of a
mystical saga from a novel, rather than
an Adult Swim show from the person who conceived
"Dexter's Laboratory" and "Hotel Transylvania."
"So what do you want a cookie? You
did alright, man. Move on already."
Deliberately historically inaccurate to maximize
drama and possibility, "Primal" takes place in a
distant prehistoric time period. Here, humans,
earlier evolutions of humankind, and dinosaurs
all live among each other fighting to survive
and thrive. The action centers on Spear,
a Neanderthal and caveman left alone in a brutal
world when a pack of dinosaurs kills his family.
He befriends a small dino named Fang whose
family was killed by the same vicious clan.
They form a de facto unit and a strong bond, which
fuels the action in the almost critically-perfect
Season 2 of "Primal." Spear and Fang face
all sorts of internal and external conflicts,
from a giant shark to more advanced
groups of humans — and the animation
team behind it all was up to the
task. Tartakovsky told Indiewire,
"There are a number of episodes where there
are eight to 10-minute fight sequences,
and each one of those almost broke the studio."
"Atlanta" is a thoughtful, meditative, surreal
look at modern life, particularly for young Black
men balancing artistic pursuits with the need
to make enough money to pull themselves out of
poverty in a hostile world. It's a dazzling series
that changes its tone as the story requires, with
each season and episode wildly different from the
last. Created, chiefly written by, and starring
comedian-actor-musician Donald Glover, "Atlanta"
routinely churns out 30-minute masterpieces.
According to "Metacritic", the best of these
fall within Season 2 of the show. This season
is subtitled "Robbin' Season" to reflect
a certain desperation felt by the extended
universe of characters in this barely fictional
representation of the titular Southern metropolis.
The final part of the final season of the final
chapter of the "Breaking Bad" saga certainly
stuck the landing. Bob Odenkirk joined the
cast of "Breaking Bad" midway through its
run as Saul Goodman, a sleazy bus-bench
lawyer who helps with the legal issues
of the show's various drug manufacturing and
distributing characters. He was so compelling,
AMC commissioned the spinoff "Better Call
Saul," The "Breaking Bad" prequel that
showed how small-time hustler
and part-time public defender
Jimmy McGill evolved into a swaggering
wheeler-dealer of questionable morality.
By Season 6.5 of "Better Call Saul," the
transformation from Jimmy to Saul nears its
completion, while the rest of the "Breaking Bad"
backstory also gets filled in. Character-driven
and empathetic, the final slew of "Better
Call Saul" episodes also give quite a few
glimpses into what became of Jimmy after he had
to abandon his life and identity as Saul Goodman.
"Look at that."
It seems Saul mostly lives his life alone,
depressed, and working at a Cinnabon. But
the last few episodes show us it doesn't
stay that way forever. Saul starts up
his old scams again, and all of a sudden,
his old life begins to catch up with him.
Based on acclaimed Italian novelist
Elena Ferrante's books of the same name,
"My Brilliant Friend" was produced for
Italian television but airs in the U.S.
on HBO. Ferrante has co-written every
episode of the critically lauded series,
which tells a story of a triumph-and-tragedy
filled friendship between two girls from
a poor neighborhood near Naples
who met as children in the 1950s.
At the outset of Season 3,
it's the dawn of the 1970s,
and Lila and Elena have taken
very different paths into their
young adulthoods. Lila is struggling,
having married at 17, birthed a child,
and left her husband. She finds herself working
in a meat processing factory to support herself.
Meanwhile, Elena has left Naples, become a famous
author, and lives comfortably among the wealthy
literary elite. As each season tells a different
part of the long saga, and is set in a different
era, the filmic nature of "My Brilliant Friend"
changes. Season 3 embraces the aesthetic of
its 1970s settings, emulating the look and
feels of American indie movies of the era.
"Murder One" is not as well known
as many of the series on this list,
but that doesn't mean the show wasn't
influential. Lasting for only two seasons,
"Murder One" was created by Steven Bochco
and broke the mold when it debuted in 1995,
focusing the entirety of its 1st season on a
single criminal case. In heavily serializing
its story, "Murder One" helped to more
firmly establish the idea that viewers
would be interested in the minutiae of a
case as it winds its way towards a trial.
Paired with award-winning cinematography
by filmmake Aaron Schneider, "Murder
One"'s formula-breaking plot managed
to make every detail of the criminal
case more fascinating than the last.
As a documentary, "Planet Earth II" might not
seem like it belongs on this list of dramas,
but let's trust Metacritic on this one.
There's only one season of "Planet Earth
II," but this sequel to the original
"Planet Earth" proves that nature
documentaries don't have to be dry museum
material. Narrated by David Attenborough,
"Planet Earth II" is an ode to the
wildlife that exists all over the planet.
The footage is breathtaking and remarkably
vivid, and it serves as a reminder that the
world contains beauty that doesn't require any
sort of computer-generated enhancement. The 2016
miniseries, which was released 10 years after its
predecessor, also serves as an urgent reminder of
all that the world stands to lose if nothing is
done to combat the threat of industrialization and
climate change. The documentary isn't explicitly
political, but merely by documenting the natural
beauty of the ecosystems and wildlife around
us, the film highlights their imperiled state.